bibble d boop and gobbledygook coffee on
a Tuesday in blog 41 reading over last
week's Sunday times I came across this
article by Christie wonpil how to live
without irony John Paul airs out certain
grievances and irritation she has about
hipsters the archetype she says of
ironic living the hipster haunts every
city street in university town
manifesting a nostalgia for times he
never lived himself this contemporary
urban Harlequin appropriates outmoded
fashions the mustache tiny shorts
mechanisms fixed-gear bicycles portable
record players and hobbies homebrewing
playing trombone he harvests awkwardness
and self-consciousness before he makes
any choice he has proceeded through
several stages of self scrutiny and
wouldn't it be nice if columnist
proceeded through those same several
stages of self scrutiny themselves she
continues I to exhibit ironic tendencies
for example I find it difficult to give
sincere gifts instead I often give what
in the past would have been accepted
only at a white elephant gift exchange a
kitschy painting from a thrift store a
coffee mug with flashy images of Texas
the Lone Star State plastic Mexican
wrestler figures the simple act of
noticing myself defensive behavior has
made me think deeply about how
potentially toxic ironic posturing could
be the simple act of noticing myself
defensive behavior has made me think
deeply about how potentially maybe I'm
guessing that you guys are bad gift
givers to write ok so the crux of this
article is that ironic living
exemplified by hipsters is a defense
mechanism that allows us to Eve aid the
vulnerable intensity of naked personal
interaction she hangs a lot of this on
the digital toys we carry around with us
and a deep desire for sentimentality and
us doubt and I must say that nostalgia
sentimentality and defense mechanisms
are all conditions that I suffer from
they also happen to be numbers 12 35 and
63 respectively of the human condition
for a full list of the human conditions
you can visit yourself
and yet even if I suffer from these
symptoms I don't know that you could
diagnose me with the supposed endemic of
ironic living really I don't know anyone
when you get down to it who you could
diagnose with that after I came back
from Paris the most frequent question I
was asked was not really a question at
all more of a statement with a question
mark at the end of it French people
don't like Americans right this I found
perplexing because for the six months
that I lived there
not a single French person treated me
poorly for my Americanists and
affliction I am no doubt soaked in fact
the people I met there were so generous
the relationships so easily formed and
quickly deep that I was doubly perplexed
by the stereotype to these people I
answered invariably every man is his own
man every woman her own woman kind
people like to be treated kindly and
French people who walk around with sad
faces like to be asked what's wrong in
France and at home I have friends who
have typewriters and fixed-gear bicycles
who brew their own beer and cover their
walls with stuff they found on the side
of the street some are politically
active others not so much some are
certain who they are and what they want
to do others not so much
sometimes they look at their phones when
I talk to them other times they walk
around with sad faces I asked them
what's wrong and they tell me sometimes
they ask me finally want poll rights
what will future generations make of
this rampant sarcasm and unapologetic
cultivation of silliness will we be
satisfied to leave an archive filled
with video clips of people doing stupid
things stupid things huh exhibit a
charlie McDonald's last video I'm scared
Exhibit B 920 1835 views Exhibit C
40,000 72 comments I'm proud to be part
of an archive of passionate people
saying sincere things and I'm convinced
that what we do is contagious and if I
may be so bold as to state a common
mission it's to circulate with force the
notion that every person is at all times
going through something that it's not
right to judge individuals based on
groups if it is at any time right to
judge individuals period a simple
message but a strong one and I was sure
that understanding it was part of the
interview process for professors at
Princeton University
don't get me started on anything
professors late winter afternoon if you
are in fair you told me that the world
didn't care didn't care hey mister I'm
going up the stairs
well sister you can meet me there oh I
know it's alright with you